a lot of respect for every opponent not
just Magnus you have to lose all respect
in Armageddon you need to flag your
opponent you need to use the clock as a
weapon and right now you know Magnus
he's had been shielded with increment
doesn't have that anymore so lamb has to
play quickly play sharply and just say
to Magnus you know what I may be a solid
player but here I have to go all in
Queen's camber decline something that
he's used to play at E6 right something
something cool here okay maybe yeah and
queen's game of decline Here We Go Again
wow what is this station another Catalan
and Magnus is the one thinking early
dose it's a bit surprising his last
black game he equalized very very easily
and I would say if you if it's not
broken why fix it and uh okay why is he
thinking it is a race against the clock
I think it's a bit psychological because
Magnus has not won the players who like
to repeat the same opening over and over
again so even though he had success with
it just a moment ago he says I'm not
going to play the same one and this is
actually what both players want Magnus
well prepared but for lamb it's not just
a simple straight forward symmetrical
structure in fact white has the bishop
pair now but White's Pawn structure is a
bit compromised I find that this is a
very cool way to actually kind of almost
neutralize the cattle in here but at
least we get to get rid of that
ridiculously strong Bishop on G2 if you
ever move the Knight you don't have a
knight C3 coming I mean Black's just for
choice I mean all all the way here now I
do like white has the bishop pair you
can try to make some some problems
obviously try to get E4 in that's what
you want in cattle anyway maybe play
Bishop to B2 Rook B1 but black actually
is just totally fine in this position
slow on the clock any trades favor
Magnus and Robert is that the reason why
he's gone for a central break with C5
there'll be tension you can flag your
opponent later but pieces will come off
Magnus is so good uh to turning things
his way and okay A bit of a mysterious
Pawn push there Magnus now I'm pretty
sure we'll just move his Queen out
connect the black Rooks bring them to
the center nothing to worry about here
just rock solid and all you need is a
draw perfect scenario for black
now connected I mean I'm finishing my
development I'm feeling good the OC file
is going to open you got weak pawns here
neutralize the Catalan Bishop this feels
like a disaster I'm not even gonna lie
for as a Catalan player here on takes
takes I mean what is this I'm supposed
to play for a win here guys my Queen's
off the board how do I you know this is
this is over yeah at least he's improve
this pull structure there's more gains
here but yeah off to this important
capture if the white knight goes and
takes this Pawn back actually you end up
losing material you have to be really
careful how uh you recapture this Pawn
okay he brings us to the center let's
just show that on the board if you were
Hasty here if you were greedy and took
this Pawn back after a trade of Bishops
whoops this is a double attack a fork
and lose a piece lose the Armageddon
immediately so the white Rook has slid
across but now Magnus is simply going to
occupy the open file I'm not sure which
Rook you use but he's going to bring his
rook in and uh black is fine there's
just nothing to Target in Black's
position white is the one who's down
upon temporarily and has to protect
other pawns this has not gone Lamb's way
and I don't think this is biased I think
it's just objective evaluation the
position Liam himself will be the first
to admit that this has not gone the way
he wanted and for Magnus his moves are
quite straightforward which means he's
not even get into severe time trouble
unfortunately for Liam he's playing
somebody who does not lose very often
and to win on demand is difficult
against anyone but Magnus Carlson
sometimes impossible right and you're
trying to squeeze the squeezer right it
just doesn't work that way you know it's
very difficult especially in a must-win
situation if this was okay if you're
okay with the draw that's cool but not
in this situation I think uh this
opening Choice definitely is not going
to be uh he's going to be kicking
himself for this one you can't sleep
repertoire he's clearly done his
homework against the Catalan Magnus and
uh Liam meanwhile because he was maybe
affected by those Mind Games chose wrong
in the opening he chose an opening that
Magnus knows everything about you need
to catch him off guard you need to
provoke him uh if you want to take him
down he does have this unique ability to
get into his opponent's Minds where we
see him outbid in the Armageddon time
and time time again what was most
impressive was the margin that he did it
with disadvantage that Lim had and
stayed throughout the game so he
realized them can't bid that against
Fabiano if they repeated that he
wouldn't bid it against Magnus so he
learned from it playing that active
position he never got the kind of
positions that he would enjoy playing
and here we see the pieces are being
trade off more and more which means it
is Advantage Magnus because he needs
just to draw Robert is taking your point
following up on that point that you
mentioned the biggest problem here is
that a draw just doesn't suffice I think
Liam should have played uh the London
system of course because he does have a
London course he has one of the best
chance of London courses right you have
other ones too as well but his is one of
the best especially as a super GM too as
well very great you know system I think
he probably should have went for that
just to maybe play something different
get some different positions here
because this I mean this was a Magnus
had no trouble at all Blitz the moves
out me Barely Used any time then he
started with 10 minutes right this one
it is hard to imagine white creating
anything and we see the clocks are
leveling out as well David is there
anything left in this position can white
create something with that lone Bishop
well that's going to be traded off as
well now yeah I think I think the
question is can black women can black
play for more look at those beautiful
black knights in the center of the board
look at that beautiful black Rook just
uh x-ray vision across the second rank
looks like it's holding together by a
thread fullium it should still be a draw
but it might be Magnus getting
enthusiastic getting excited here yeah
Magnus has done enough just about enough
but enough to progress he probably
should have taken down Hikaru Nakamura
yesterday uh it was just unfortunate for
him Misfortune in that end game that he
couldn't break through and made a slip
there but I think that players who are
very solid we often comment them for
their Precision they're really hard to
take down but when they need a win on
demand they often struggle to get it
because they don't go outside of their
comfort zones also they can play solid
which helps in situations like this as
Magnus is showing really cynical chess
but it's effective chess just trading
off the remaining imbalance now the
night for Bishop imbalance has
disappeared symmetrical Pawn structure
will ensure a draw here Magnus though
setting up tricks setting up potential
traps maybe the pawns will step forward
kick away the white king from the
defense of his Knight
the m has to be careful to hold this one
wow it's just saying that I had this in
the bag the whole time I think Liam kind
of knew that too in a way I mean he is
down you do you know your opponent your
real record against opponents here but
he's going to fight and I mean he did
and it's just it's not looking good
though for Liam by uh giving up his Rook
the White Knight is a bit stuck a bit
pinned if it had moved on this last go
sorry uh then nice Rook sacrifice Rook
takes Pawn check and a nasty Fork this
is what white has to watch out for uh
next move the Rook will disappear and
black would be uh with the advantage
four versus three meanwhile white moved
his Rook but this did allow Magnus now
to throw in a check and just to show
what happens if the pawn is captured uh
it has been captured the first point at
least Rook takes Knight Rook takes
Knight Rook takes Borden everything off
the board two versus two draw
immediately I love the difference
between American English and British
English
we say vacuum you know it's okay I get
it but I'm just saying I appreciate it
you know our differences is what makes
us special and I is
oh
okay okay
wow and I think just to point it out a
little bit that there was a nasty little
trap there set up David yeah
yes night I think everyone got excited
for a second by Rook takes Knight it
looks like it wins because after King
takes there's a nasty night fork and
black picks up the white Rook but don't
what uh don't forget about those checks
watch out because Sonny White flicks in
a check the king moose now after King
takes Rook the king and Knight King and
Rook sorry are sufficiently far apart
for uh them to avoid any Forks black
would have been on the blundered here
trickster gets tricked as they say
instead we go to this position limbs
kept the knights alive he kept the game
going the problem is he's still stuck
the black Rook along this rank look how
strong it is just keeping white
completely tied down Black's Knight
holds all the other pawns and still no
way to make progress for white with a
little less than five minutes and a
position where it's hard to imagine
white making any progress while he is
going after the H Pawn but both these
pawns are going to be traded off James
absolutely I get one you get one same
same appreciate it right you know thank
you thank you buddy appreciate it right
take it and that's really it we got to
move the Knight you have to take take
and maybe put the Knight on F5 very
strong post for it maybe go to E3 after
that there it is Knight of five plate
and I mean there's no way I'm losing
this game unless I mean even Knight G3
looks good too I think we'll see him
again a hundred percent and we've seen
him have a great performance in the past
seasons of The Champions Chester but it
just feels like Robert that in these
formats being Mr Nice Guy it doesn't
help
I've got to be nasty gotta be nasty
right now oh man yeah I mean as Robert
pointed out to me Liam played great
chess here this is a draw three draws I
didn't lose right I mean I didn't lose
but I'm still getting eliminated I'm not
even worse in any position in any game
correct all right rookie one played
defunded the pawn black advances the
king liama is going to play it down but
we can't even imagine a possible
flagging scenario here I can he'll get
flagged he's the one who's down a lot of
time now but he cried to him he keeps
trying to find ways to keep the game
going uh but unfortunately against
Magnus Magnus hasn't given him an ounce
of hope uh White's pieces are tied down
Black's pieces are more active and they
both know what the result was likely
going to be from an early stage but for
them he kept going and finally there is
that exchange sacrifice liquidates
everything yeah and night Fork picks
back the material gets that white rook
and we will see I think for the third
time out of three games King versus King
damn that's how close it's been how hard
they fought and Magnus does progress he
does and it is the end of the road for
Liam a heartbreaking moment but Liam